so now that i've written it in this form
you can see this is just a regular old
quadratic i mean it's a terrible looking
one but this is my
a this is my b
and this is my c the entire finger so
what i can say
is using the quadratic formula because i
do not want to try and factorize this
thing
i can say tan x equals and then i can
just launch into minus b
plus or minus the square root of b
squared minus 4ac all over 2a so let's
write out what that looks like
i'm going to start with my minus and
then here comes b
it's a negative 2 plus or minus square
root of
b squared which is negative 2 squared
minus 4 and then i do a and c
and then conveniently for me you might
notice this 1 plus root 3 which is
a and my 1 minus root 3 which is
c these are actually conjugates so this
is going to end up
something which will cancel out
reasonably neatly for me so i'm going to
draw the radical sign over there all of
that is divided through
by 2a which is 2 outside of 1
plus root 3. okay let's change that
thickness back okay good
now this looks terrible but um i can
work with it so
uh stay with it for a second we've got a
lot of things to simplify here so
negative of negative 2 just gives me a
2. i've got plus or minus here comes the
square root
this is 4 outside of 4 minus rather
4 outside of now i can then do my
difference of squares
so this is a squared minus b squared so
this is going to be
1 squared minus root 3 or squared so
that's a 3.
and that's everything underneath this so
i'm going to draw
the rest of the square root sign over
there and then
on the bottom i still have the 2 outside
1 plus root 3
that i had before so that looks really
good we're done
i can now simplify a little bit further
so i notice
that you've got a common factor of 4
underneath this square root but if
you're taking the square root of that
the square root of 4 is just 2. so what
i'm going to get is 2
plus or minus 2 i've factored out the
square root of 4.
that leaves me with conveniently
1 minus and the 1 minus 3
is going to be negative 2. the following
with me there you can see
um how i've factored out that that
square root of 4 it ends up here and the
2
and then i've also done this 1 minus 3
which gives me negative 2.
it's a double digit you just have to be
quite careful and then all that
is outside of or over 1 plus root
3. so you can see what i can do is i can
actually say these twos
are all common factors so i can cancel
everything out there
so that gives me 1 plus or minus now
what's underneath the square root what's
1 take away negative 2
which is three and then i'm left with
a one plus root three on the bottom so
even though we came from this garbled
mess okay something has ended up
quite simple down the bottom what do we
get well this one planets minus root
three is actually two different
solutions so there's
the positive case one plus root three
and then you
also have the negative case one minus
root three
that's divided by one plus root three as
well and conveniently over here i get
one over here on the right hand side
you're like
i need to um i need to cancel this a
little bit i need to rationalize this
denominator to make it a little bit
easier to work with
so if i multiply the top and the bottom
by oops that's the wrong thing to
multiply by by the conjugate
of the bottom so 1 minus root 3.
you can see what am i going to get on
the top well it's 1 minus root 3 all
squared so that's going to be 1 minus 2
root 3 plus 3.
all of that's divided by i'm using my
difference of squares again with the
conjugate of that
certic term so 1 minus 3.
how's this going to come out well what
do i get on the top i've got 4
minus two root three i've got negative
two
on the bottom i'm almost there one or
okay i can divide everything
through on the top by negative two that
gives me i think
root three minus two okay
that's as far as i can simplify these
are my two solutions for tan
x but of course i'm looking for a
solution in x so i need to think
what's the angle x that would give me 1
or negative sorry root 3 minus 2
if i took the tan of that angle now here
is the moment at last which i can
actually return
back earlier to the question where i
said well we had to deal with this
domain restriction right right here well
we didn't have to touch it at all we've
just been using
identities and algebra to deal with
these things but now i have to say i'm
solving some trigonometric equations
or two of them and i need to make sure i
find solutions in the right area
now one of the handy things and this is
it's somewhat coincidental
is that when you think about what what
tan x looks like within this particular
domain
what you end up with is something looks
like this
so my solutions are going to be found
quite uniquely there's going to be one
solution for our tan x
equals one and there will be one
solution for root three minus two
how do we find them well the first one
is actually very easy
when i'm doing ten inverse of one that's
actually an exact angle that's pi
on four and thankfully that was one that
we got earlier which is really nice to
know
i've confirmed but i got my correct
answer then when you have a look at the
other one
you have to think about this right root
three is about 1.7
so 1.7 take away 2 it's
about negative 0.3 so when i go to find
my solutions for this right
i already found my solution for tan x
equals 1. it's uh
you know there's my y equals 1. so there
is the solution
roughly okay when i go for tan x equals
a negative 0.3
i'm expecting a solution down here y
equals negative 0.3 roughly anyway
so it's somewhere around there it's
going to be
a fairly large obtuse angle if you want
to think about it that way
now i do not know my exact value for
this because i'm like root three minus
two and remember is that
so here you need your calculator to help
you a little bit
and what i can do is i can say what is
tan inverse
of root 3 minus 2 is that going to give
me something
useful so how do we deal with this well
let me just check if i'm in
radians or degrees you can do this both
in radians and degrees it might actually
be helpful if we do this in degrees
first because
the numbers we're going to deal with are
probably easier to see because they
won't have pies involved okay
so what i'm going to do is i'll leave
that in degrees and i'll say
what is tan inverse of root three
and then i'm going to come out at the
square root minus two
now you can see here my answer is
negative 15 degrees but that's not
within my domain restriction my domain
restriction is from naught degrees
to 180 degrees pi radians so therefore
in order to go from here to a reasonable
angle
i need to take advantage of the fact
that 10 is periodic so if you have a
think about this
negative 15 where is that negative 15
is it's off here on the left right it's
this angle
over here negative 15. it's just a
little bit to the left
so what i need to do is taking advantage
of the periodicity of tan
i'm going to get another solution 180
degrees or pi
radians later because that's how
frequently tan x
copies so if i add pi radians to that or
if i add 180 degrees that
i will get another solution so what i'll
do is
coming to my calculator i'll add 180
oops 180 not 181 there we go
so i get 165 degrees and for those of
you who are now trying to think
what is that going to be equal to in
radians 165 degrees what i need to
multiply by
is pi on 180 that's my conversion factor
so
if i take 165
and then divide that by 180 you can see
i get 11 on 12. so this is actually 11
pi on 12. now i didn't say before you
can just do this directly
in radians you don't have to um convert
into you know back and forth between
degrees so how would that look
well let me show you if i switch over to
radians mode on my calculator here
i will go through much the same process
so i will say
tan inverse of root 3
minus 2. and then i get this solution
but i know that that is still not within
the domain that i was looking for i want
a solution between naught
and pi this is a negative answer
negative 0.26 etc
now when i think about this the
periodicity of tan is still something
that i can use but instead of adding 180
degrees i'm going to add pi radians like
i mentioned
over here on my graph before it's the
same idea
adding pi radians is adding 180 degrees
so what i'll do is i'll add that pi
great now i have an answer between nor
and pi this is between naught and zero
point
sorry 3.14 so this is good but i can't
read that
2.879 et cetera i don't know what that
exact value is equal to
now because i know if it's going to be a
nice exact value it's going to have a pi
hiding in there it is a reasonable guess
to divide this answer by pi so if i do
that divide by pi
you can see i got that same fraction
that i got before the answer includes
the pi in it so it'll be 11 pi on 12
like i saw earlier
so that's just to confirm that i got the
same answer in radians as in degrees
and thankfully i get the same answer
that i did when i went through this
other path
i'm trying to modify the domain from the
outset and use that to think about
different relative solutions
so all of that just to say is this the
best way to solve this problem
no it's not however you can gain a lot
of insight by solving problems in
different ways and it's a real relief
that even though we went this
long circuitous route that required
different knowledge sure enough if we
use that knowledge
accurately we will end up at the same
solution so
hope you found that useful